so as many of you know when we made our
a studio move several months ago we
redesigned the look of the David Pakman
show studio and in so preparing I spoke
to different people including Sam cedar
of the majority report and one of the
things I talked to Sam about is how he
set up the paneling that's behind him
and I purchased the same style panel to
be behind me and we integrated into the
set with a television and sort of
different coloring and lighting and
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah
so recently someone during one of my
live streams on YouTube sent the super
chat asking about it and then that
person called in to sam cedars show the
majority report and asked him about my
comment about it and sam played my
answer to the question about it we're
now like three levels of Inception deep
and it's really funny take a listen to
this
Steven Robin says is it true that you
literally asked Sam cedar how to build
his set before you copied it yes I did
I mean the difference is I've set it up
I've combined our old set which has this
screen behind me with similar paneling
I mean basically what what I copied was
I asked him how did he build the panel's
and he told me and I'm curious the I've
said that Sam helped me pack is going to
cut this segment and comment on this
segment and then what we're gonna do is
we're gonna cut the segment that he
comments on this segment and that's
basically going to be our business our
business memorize their plans yeah
that's exactly right so now I'm
commenting on this segment let me let me
make clear lest anyone be confused our
set is still in progress so more changes
are still forthcoming
but there's a much funnier part of this
segment actually on Sam's show which is
that caller who called in to Sam's show
to talk about the set piece it's the set
element he
called and sort of complained to Sam or
I guess was kind of like incredulous
about the fact that during my youtube
live streams people send in paid
questions for me to answer through
something called super chat
I find this part hilarious he just seems
totally incredulous that people would do
that so I turn it on and he's reading
questions like comments and questions
but they're these YouTube super chats
that you have to pay for right and these
questions are just pouring in like ten
dollars a pop people are asking like
what do you think about Cory Booker and
somebody paid like ten dollars to get
him to answer that right okay Kurt what
we have we also tried to and people do
that I mean I this is just what of this
may be my favorite majority report clip
ever the guy just can't believe that the
super chats are pouring in during my
live streams and then the caller is
angry not only about super shots but
about the fact that sometimes we'll have
a new member goal during live streams
before I take phone calls on on the live
stream the problem again how much like
pay me to respond to what you're saying
getting to the good part okay sorry so
he's he says that he has a phone number
that he's going to take calls but that
he won't do it until he gets 10 new
subscribers 10 new patrons or whatever
oh this is this is interesting it's
holding he's got a gun to the phone's
well and he's holding them hostage right
thing and guess what he got there very
quickly and it just seems like you're
leaving a lot of money on the table my
guy kind of thing well I mean I mean so
what should I do I could say like we're
gonna have we if we get 10 members I'm
going to start answering the phones
today we should do that every day like
by having guys we're new members so this
is just the best so now we're going to
create a never-ending
a nested loop of comments on each other
segments about the set it's going to be
sort of like those Russian dolls or the
movie Inception someone super chatted me
to ask about Sam set then they called
Sam's show to talk to Sam about it Sam
played my clip in order to respond to
the call about the super chat on my
channel about Sam said now I'm
responding to Sam's comment about a
caller's comment about a caller super
chat about my build out of the set which
resembles Sam said and then of course
the night Pat the progressive voice
known as the progressive TMZ on YouTube
will comment on the entire thing and
then it'll all sort of start over
tomorrow well there is a lot to comments
on here and you did promise me that no
one was going to notice that you copied
Sam set so I'm a little worried about
the fallout here I don't know where this
is going to end up but I'm not prepared
for another five or six response videos
I don't think the show is prepared
either no well I'm actually hiring Rudy
Guiliani to represent me on this matter
on TV shows because he's just so good at
talking people out of awkward situations
so he will now be talking about this
going forward by the way later today I'm
going to be asking Sam for his social
security and bank account numbers just
so I can figure out how those work
before I start using my own as well so
many more exciting segments to talk
about